good afternoon we start with breaking
news this hour scientists stress that
more research is required but early
findings from public health England
suggest that vaccines might not be
effective in reducing the
transmissibility of the Delta variant of
Coronavirus
well let's cross straight away to our
health correspondent Ashish Joshi who
can give us more information on this
Ashish just how worried do we need to be
at the moment just a little concerned I
think I've spoken to the the people at
Public Health England this morning and
they are Keen to stress these are very
early findings these are the initial
findings and a lot more research needs
to be carried out to see exactly what
this means for the long-term
implications for the vaccine and for the
Delta variant what this is the weekly
technical briefing this is what the phe
scientists have found out and they make
it public and during the course of their
research they found that and I'll read
to you from the the public health
England guidance they said that they
found from their initial research that
levels of the virus and those who became
in who become infected with Delta having
already been vaccinated might be similar
to levels found in unvaccinated people
essentially what that means is that's
the viral load the levels of the virus
contained within a a person now if
they're the same if you're vaccinated or
unvaccinated that might impact the
transmissibility of that virus I.E the
ability to pass on that virus to another
person if you've been vaccinated we have
been told all along and the research has
found that the vaccines reduce
transmissibility now these initial
findings seeming to suggest that they
might not be as effective active as once
believed I do stress it's very early
days these initial findings and a lot
more research needs to be carried out
but this is something that will concern
the scientists and vaccinologists who
have always said that the
transmissibility is is greatly reduced
by having two doses of the vaccine
initial findings seeming to suggest that
the viral loads in people uh could be
similar for the Delta variant whether
vaccinated or unvaccinated
just while you've been speaking Ashish
we've had some breaking news drop from
the ons with a new figure that an
estimated one in 75 people in England
have had coronavirus in the latest week
of data the last uh figure we had for
that was one in 65 so one in 75 people
in England with covert this week
compared to one in 65
last week what do you make of that well
that's that's better news it means that
we might be seeing uh that the virus the
impact the virus and the spread of the
virus being curtailed right we know that
there's been a huge effort to try and
get the vaccination levels up we know
that the vaccination levels will have an
impact on the spread of the virus but
certainly this seems to be going the way
we we had hoped it might and and that is
promising news we did see early signs of
it we see it every day in the numbers of
people new infections new cases are
beginning to fall we had that week where
they fell every single day for seven
days consecutively and this is good
because if you look at the context and
the warnings which were sounded by the
health sector and the government about
the peak being mid-august when we could
see a hundred thousand cases per day
that hasn't thankfully happened so
certainly the the figures going in the
right direction